so
the title of my talk is
is on network systems and one of the
things that happened
when i was a doe was a
um you know it's really learning
from or drinking from the fire hose
above the electricity grid
and so what i'm going to do is to share
some of the lessons learned
of um of our lessons learned
and sort of the emerging trends that are
going on in the electricity grid
and there are three networks that are
getting coupled more and more the
electricity natural gas
and the information network and
i mentioned in my title lessons learned
there are actually
few lessons learned because not much has
happened
and what i'm going to talk about is what
needs to happen
so that we can get those lessons so it's
a slight change of title
now this infrastructure was claimed to
be
by the national academy of engineering
the greatest
engineering achievement of the 20th
century and it's true i mean everything
sort of
relies on this electricity
infrastructure you don't have
electricity for a couple of days and
you know things uh people get upset
and it is really the the icon of
any modern economy and without
electricity i mean it's called the
second industrial revolution
and without electricity really nothing
runs
and in fact a whole information network
is based on electricity
so but the key word out here is 20th
century
and the question is what's going to
happen what's likely to happen in the
21st century
before i focus in the united states i'm
going to step
back and look at the world and give you
a picture
of what the challenges and the
opportunities are
this is the population density of the
world
and we are right over here somewhere and
but this is the rest of the world you
can see where the popular people are
a lot of people out here and out here
etc
and i'm going to overlay on top and i
hope you get to see this
the lighting of the world which tells
you where
the electricity is flowing and what you
immediately see is that united states
we've got a lot of people and it's
bright
we need to make it brighter in a
sustainable way
but there are many parts of the world
where people have not yet turned on the
lights so to speak
and the question is okay how many
are we talking about so let me give you
some numbers
number one is there are three billion
people out of seven
who have either no or very limited
access to electricity
no is 1.5 and very limited access is
another one 1.5 or so when i say limited
access is that
they have the wires with the but the
power is not flowing the electrons are
there but the power is not flowing
okay so it's three billion almost half
the world's population
by 2050 additional two billion people
will be added to the same regions
that this is going on okay and it'll be
about half
so the population growth is faster than
the electrification
in some places number three there are
massive levels of urbanization that are
going on as we speak
and the demands on electricity
infrastructure is huge and can't keep up
with the demand and finally
the question that we're trying to answer
is that we have an electricity
infrastructure
which compared to the rest of the world
seems really good so the question is how
can we modernize infrastructure
and the second question is how can we
provide access to affordable electricity
to every human being
i mean i consider this to be a human
right because if you do not have
electricity
you do not get into the modern economy
okay and you're stuck
in a certain stratum of of income levels
etc
there is no economic growth so this is
these are the big
big questions that we're trying to
answer and the question is why we're
trying to modernize infrastructure
is it for you know just to modernize or
is there a need for it and i'm going to
sort of give you
what that need is so my talk is outlined
in three topics one is what is the
current paradigm
of electricity infrastructure secondly
what are the emerging trends and finally
what is the shifting paradigm and we're
living through that
and it's you know as opposed to in a
computer science which
happens very quickly seemingly at least
you know
to the public um this takes time
and it's going to take time so what is
that current paradigm
the current paradigm is the following
our electricity grid
looks like this this is the current
architecture you have
a centralized big power station mostly
thermal power plants
you generate a lot of power you take it
long distance at high voltages
to transmission lines and you need high
voltages because you want the currents
to be low
and thereby the losses to be low that's
where the high voltage is
and then it comes to local distribution
you know networks and you have a
distribution substation where you drop
the voltage and then you get these
feeder lines near your neighborhood
which is like 13 kilovolts that are
running
and then from those you have
transformers which give you
you know 240 volts out of which you take
half of it you get 120 volts
in your home that's the architecture
that's the paradigm that we're living in
and it turns out
that this this architecture goes back to
tesla and edison
the architecture has not changed the
devices may have changed
but this arc this this construct has not
really changed
and it is based on again the centralized
generation
one-way power flow to zillions of load
why centralized generation
because these are all thermal power
plants and in thermal power plants
the economies of scale suggest that
bigger is better
and that's why you have one gigawatt
plants of coal-fired power plants or
nuclear power plants etc
okay so that's been the paradigm and
really this has this
has not changed so what have we
you know so it turns out that because of
this technology technological paradigm
our institutions have been framed around
it
our legal framework regulatory framework
have been
has been framed around this this
paradigm so everything and the business
models goes along with it
so the technology is sort of the key out
here and i'll talk
a little bit about the institutions
because they're these are all coupled
together
so what have we done well this is what
we have built up this is the high
voltage transmission
network in the united states and these
are different voltages
and for really long distance you need
the higher really high voltages
in the united states it goes up to 765
kilovolts
in china now they have a million volts
both ac and dc
and you know they're ahead so
in terms of you know what have we done
to this
infrastructure in terms of information
what is this smart grid all about well
let me sort of dispel some myths out
here
so what have we done if you look at the
transmission network
we have put this these are called phaser
measurement units we have about 1000
in the united states and this is what it
looks like
it it looks at data and it you know this
is what happens these are pmus
it measures the current it measures
the frequency okay we are all at 60
hertz
but it's not exactly 60 hertz it
measures the time there's a time stamp
there's a voltage
there's a location there's a relative
phase phase
angle and it samples every 30
millisecond and it sends out data
and you're getting peta scales of data
now okay that's what's going on
of course there's communication this
data needs to be communicated and
frankly we have
in a relatively advanced you know
communication
with this and with with security built
into this
in terms of improved communication for
these uh for these units
and finally what we have not done well
is you know the computing part what do
you do with the data
and i'll come back to that later on
again
this is for the trans high voltage
transmission network
that's only part of the system it
doesn't talk about the distribution
network
so if we have put these units in this
middle of the network at the high
voltage part
what else have you done when you say you
put them in the network do these
measuring devices have to be
connected they have to be connected
absolutely the hull sensors and all that
they have to
sort of measure what the current is
flowing they're magnetically coupled
but yeah that's right right
so so that's what's going on now the
other side the
this is in the middle of the network and
now i'm talking i'll talk about the edge
of the network
this is what we have smart meters okay
and we have these are right at the at
this point out here
and you can measure you know the current
and voltage and power
and there's been a wide deployment in
fact both the pmu
the phasor measurement units as well as
the smart meters a lot of that was
deployed using the stimulus the thousand
pmus as well as the smart meters
that was part of the effort is to put
some get some numbers get some data out
of it
which is actually a good thing and if
you look at the deployment we have about
about 50 plus million smart meters out
there this is quite a bit
and they're sending data you know every
you know 10 minutes 15 minutes or so
okay so that's all we have done really
there's what is missing largely missing
is what's the data in between the
distribution network in fact many of the
utilities
don't even know where the wires are
that's the state of the art
and you know and we still you know they
still pump power in one end
the power comes out of the other end but
there's no idea what happens in between
okay so that is where we are
so question really is what can or
should we do with the data there are
lots of data out there
and i would what is going on right now
to some extent is diagnostics
you know it'll be great to have
situational awareness we don't have for
the full grid
but we have for little bits and pieces
monitoring outages
failures and billing the smart meters
are great for billing you don't have to
send someone out there to read this the
wheel going round and round
anymore at least in those 50 million
ones
it save save money what we have not done
and so this is what is going on we still
don't have
full situational awareness of the whole
grid in the united states
which is broken up into pieces and i'll
come to that but that's what you know
that would be great
the second thing is operations in real
time
and that is means load and generation
control
system optimization which by the way for
the grid
for this mesh network if you're trying
to pump in power
and you want to maintain voltage the
optimal power flow
is an np heart problem and we still you
know this is not done this is done in a
very rudimentary way
and the resilience against threats
during operation
we're not doing we're not using the data
to do that today
and finally for planning it's very
important
as i show you we need some upgrades in
our grid and
how you do that in terms of capital
outlay
for utility extremely important for
financing
and we we need the data as to prioritize
you know we need to
we need to replace this this particular
substation in a transformer as opposed
to that one because this is looking bad
and that data is very very important in
terms of capital outlay for this
so this is what we should be doing and
so far
this is widely open right now
but to understand this you really have
to understand how the grid operates
today so that we can appreciate what
really needs to be done
and this is where the technology and the
institutions
and and the regulatory framework all
meet together
because they have to operate under
certain rules and laws etc
so i'm going to give you an idea of how
that actually works
so the first thing is that there's a
wholesale electricity
and i'm i'm this is electricity networks
or electricity grid
really 101 okay and there's much more
details i'll just
kim on the top to give you an idea i'm
choosing california as a canonical case
you have what i call the california
independent system operator
they run the grid they're based in
folsom california just
you know east of sacramento and what
they do
is to do wholesale high voltage transmis
transmission
bulk electricity handling they're the
guys who balance the grid
it is not pg e it is these guys who
balance the grid
and what they do and by the way because
sometimes somewhere
they cross state lines and they deal
with nevada and oregon etc
and and arizona they follow the federal
rules the federal energy regulatory
commission and they follow
the nerc rules which is the technical
arm of ferc
roughly so this is the the grid
operator which balances the grid and
this is load and generation is balanced
in real time
now what they do is to buy electricity
from from solar plants from wind plants
from nuclear plants natural gas plants
etc
or from utilities who run those plants
they can be independent
plant operators or they can be utilities
who run the plants
like pg e southern california edison in
a san diego gas electric
sacramento municipality etc and these
units
can buy and sell these units sell and
and
what they do is to have an auction every
day a stock market and i'll come to that
in a minute
but these have regions like pg e is this
white region out here
southern california edison over here
these are monopolies
out there and they have to be regulated
because they're monopolies
and so that's why these units come under
what are called the state
because they remain inside the state and
they're governed by state rules
and these units then give you the retail
market because pg
e sells us electricity at home to our
buildings out here to factories
in the local region in this white region
out here
so they are not balancing the grid
they're selling and buying from the
wholesale market
okay so that's how it it works and this
is california
utility commission public utility
commission these are the federal rules
and this is the wholesale market these
are the retail market etc
so how does the wholesale market work
well it is
it's done by market bidding process so
this is you know you have the holes in
the california iso
and people have to bid for example i bid
today
most of the electricity by the way that
is coming today was planned out
yesterday
it's not a real-time market so they they
have to estimate the load
and then they dispatch a generation so
yesterday's generation and let me just
show you it's like a big knob
so most of the generation let's say in
this case this is new england
iso it's 13 gigawatts was dispatched
yesterday
and that was already planned and it's
done by bidding process for example if i
offer
you know twenty dollars a megawatt hour
and someone offers
uh dollars a mega hour my hundred
megawatt goes first
and then someone else's you know 50
megawatts goes second
so it's a bidding process in the market
so this is called the day ahead market
so they're bidding in the day ahead so
today's bidding
happens for tomorrow then they don't get
exactly right the estimates are not
quite right
and so they go in a you know hour ahead
market
so they they correct it in within an
hour then they have a 10-minute market
five-minute market etc and then they
have a second marker which is called the
frequency regulation market
okay so this is this is trading going on
and in fact if you go to false it may
look like this
and they're looking at the whole
california grid and you know monitoring
the frequencies voltages etc
now to really appreciate this it is
important to understand
all the time scales involved so this is
now
you have a millisecond 16 milliseconds
very important because that's 60 hertz
okay one cycle you have one second one
minute one hour one day one year ten
years etc
that's the whole time scale on the one
hand you have asset planning
that is you know you gotta plan ten
years ahead or twenty years ahead
and here you have faults because you can
have
circuit breakers have a fault which can
happen below a cycle
and in between you have all kinds of
controls so this is where the day head
market is
you have the hour ahead five minute
frequency regulation etc so let me tell
you how this actually works yes
this might be a silly question but how
it sounds impossible right
you're buying my electrons but how do i
get them delivered to you
through this so you you you offer up
you know so i bid and then you say okay
i have
you know i wait my electrons are not
somebody else oh you don't know
but i put my power into a mesh network
which is the transmission grid
and and then the electrons flow
according to water down
you know there are no routers there are
absolutely no routers
there's actually one router in new york
area
it's extremely expensive so one of the
things we did in rpe
can we build cheap routers for
electricity so it's
it's a mesh network it goes down
following kirchhoff's law
okay and you just dump your power onto
the system the only thing you got to do
is to maintain voltage at the other end
and so you know sending in power to
maintain voltage at these nodes
that's the problem if you want to do it
optimally to minimize cost
that's an np-hard problem okay
well what is the voltage drop between
the power plant
i mean there's many transformers in
between that's right the most of the
voltage drop is in the transformers
the loss is total losses it's about
five to six percent or so someone may
have a better number but it's roughly
that
yeah so
how is this done most of it is actually
happening in load estimation
so we estimate load in many ways
this is the day ahead prediction based
on history weather
etc okay this is where a lot of machine
learning could actually help by the way
then you have you don't get it exactly
right and then you have the hour head
estimate
and then you have 60 hertz based
estimate and what what is that that's
the frequency regulation
that is the frequency the 60 hertz
frequency is a proxy for a mismatch
between load and generation
that means if i have too much load my
turbo machine
is going to go slow and so if it's going
at 59 hertz that means i have too much
load some generation has to be pumped up
okay and if it's going at 61 hertz then
there's
less load i can cut down generation so
that's the frequency regulation market
and by the way in in the united states
it is 60 hertz
plus minus 0.035 hertz
that's the regulation that they have to
do so this
is again this is all about load
estimation
and what they do is to is to dispatch
the generation
accordingly for what the load is so you
have
a day ahead 95 of the generation
is dispatched to day ahead today and so
you can see as i saying
300 megawatts is 60 dollars a megawatt
that will go first
and then 400 megawatts 75 of mango this
is part of the bidding process
okay and then about four percent goes
in our head about one percent goes in
the
60 hertz based market and that's how the
you know the grid is operated the
generation always follows the load so so
that
when you turn on a switch out here to
turn on the lights
some generator you don't have to worry
about controlling the load some
generator is pumping up
so that you get your electrons you get
your power out here that's how it works
that's the paradigm that tesla is in
paradigm just to give you some data
here is the day about a year ago this is
typically it happens
every day this is from cal iso
this is actual data this was the uh the
day ahead forecast
out here this is 23 gigawatts 24 25
26. so each is one gigawatt of power
so you have the day ahead market and
that was
not exactly correct in terms of
prediction this is the
hour ahead forecast and this is the
actual demand
and the difference at any given point
can be about two gigawatts
okay so that's how the load curve looks
like for california and i'll come back
to that there's some very
important implications that are going on
right now
and here is the renewables part for
example this is solar
this is geothermal and hydro and this is
the wind
people think that solar is unpredictable
is actually quite predictable
you know when the sun's going to rise
you know it's going to set and you
generally put your solar plants not in
san francisco where it's foggy
but somewhere in the desert where it's
always sunny right the problem is the
wind
is not quite predictable so that is
now on the on the whole sale in in the
transmission network in the wholesale
market
and by the way that determines the price
out here the question is what happens in
the retail market
well these people buy the electricity bg
buys the electricity
and sells you the electricity at home
how is that pricing done
it is done in a very dumb manner frankly
it is a tier structure
mostly so at home you may be paying
you know 13 cents a kilowatt hour you
know for a certain amount of kilowatt
hours spent over a month
and then if you exceed that it goes to
15 and if you exceed that it goes to
tier 3 which is 32 cents a kilowatt hour
and you have no transparency as to when
that happens you're doubling the rate of
electricity that you're paying
and this is what's going on today and
there is really little correlation
between the
dynamic price changes out here because
of a market
and the pricing out here and what you
really
want and design this is where the public
utility commission comes in
they design these rates in such a way
that you may have
the wholesale prices may exceed the
retail price once in a while
but not on an average and this
difference is the margin with the
utilities making money
and when the these wholesale prices go
up out here they have to buy high and
sell low
which is what happened during the big
energy electricity crisis in california
because of enron
because they were cooking up things
where the wholesale price would go up
and then the utilities are toast and
that's why
it you know so this is how the whole
pricing and the technology
works so let me show you some emerging
trends that are happening
which are you know which are worth
noting number one
is natural gas is going to be
hugely important for united states
because we have a lot of natural gas
and it's cheap it's the cheapest way to
produce electricity today
in the wholesale price it's about five
cents a kilowatt hour
so all the capacity buildup that
happened for example in 2013
mostly was natural gas solar etc and it
there was even some coal
out there at that time today there'll be
zero coal
and so what you're finding is a shift
between so yellow is natural gas blue is
coal
and you're finding that coal is being
substituted by natural gas
mostly because because of economics and
to some extent because
of what the regulations could be in the
future
and so this huge transition which is
very rare this faster transition by the
way in the electricity network this is
going on
and what that is bringing on is a
coupling between two networks now
which is now the electricity
infrastructure the network out here
and the natural gas network and when you
have the coupling between the two
some interesting things happen and
they're happening today
so i will now imagine you're in new
england
in boston is hard to imagine when you're
in california
but just imagine you are there and you
got the polar vortex
what happens then you need to heat your
home and heating
is mostly by natural gas so you're
finding that you got to turn on
the crank on the natural gas and you're
sucking in more
now what what's going on then in the
rest of the network is the following
because you do not have enough pipelines
in the new england area the throughput
of natural gas is not enough
so the demand is high supply is not
enough and the price of natural gas
shoots up and these are spikes about
five to six times
the average price this is natural gas
dollars dollars per million btu
ignore the units for the time being it
goes from an average about five or six
five dollars to in this case almost
twenty dollars
in i heard that in the pennsylvania area
in one cold day it went up to 120
okay so these are the spot prices going
up now because your electricity
generation
is dependent on natural gas more and
more
the electricity prices shoot up so you
find this
very nice correlation between the
natural gas prices and the electricity
prices
so if i'm a consumer i got a double
whammy now
because my national gas price goes up my
electricity price goes up
and i'm paying double in in in both of
them um
you know so there is no way today to
decouple them
because of the fact that they are we are
over reliant on this
should you be storing natural gas or
should you have a generator at the end
so that you can you can generate
electricity with your heating
no one really has a solution for this
today so that's
one trend that's going on in the
coupling
the other is weather and i want to show
you you know people
we all understand global warming the
world has warmed by
1.3 degrees celsius from the beginning
of the industrial revolution
well that's the average let me show you
the distribution
and this is the distribution of
temperatures during summer on land
in the northern hemisphere okay this is
where we live and
what it'll show you is you know the some
summers are hot summer summers are cold
so you'll see that this is the theory
you know this is the distribution
there's a theory these are hot summers
they're called summers this is deviation
from the mean and what you find this is
actual data
and what you find is surely the average
has moved the things are getting hotter
2014 was the hottest year but it's
that's only part of the story
you find that the tales of the
distribution
are reaching four to five times the
standard deviation
which had never reached before and the
tails of the distribution
have a disproportionate effect on the
infrastructure because when it gets hot
you turn on the air conditioner and the
whole system is loaded
and this is this is a really important
problem because the outages
and not necessarily california but the
rest of the country
go up when you have this kind of demand
the other so this is one trend that is
going on the second trend
is age and security
this is a typical transformer in a
distribution transformer
that goes from the high voltage
transmission to a medium voltage
in a distribution network and it turns
out
the they are installed around the world
around the country we have about a
trillion dollars of
assets in the united states on the grid
these are some of them
the average the life expectancy of these
transformers
is 40 years okay that's the life
expectancy
the average age in the united states
today is 42 years
so we're at -2 think about it this is a
fundamental infrastructure
all our information networks all depend
on this
and this is the state we are in in terms
of security let me
give you just one anecdote and here is
um here is the you know highway 101
pg e there's a big substation out here
this is morgan hill this is san jose
you're all familiar with this
and you've seen this transformer the
substation i'm sure
it turns out that in april 16th about 2
am there were people with guns
who shot at the radiators of the
transformer because they have cooling
oil running
to maintain the temperature they shot at
that so that the
50 000 gallons of cooling oil were
leaked and all they tripped the
transformers
but 15 minutes before that the fiber
optic and telephone cables were
essentially sheared off so that 911 was
disabled
and for about a year no one heard about
it we were following this closely
but no one heard about it because it
happened the same night
of the boston marathon bombing and we
still haven't caught these guys
and this is just a cyber physical threat
this is not just cyber threat
in terms of cyber threat when i was in
washington department energy my first
security briefing
that i got um in a classified briefing
and i looked at the data of what was
happening on the grid and what other
nations were sort of
meddling around and my first reaction
was i hope in
this visceral reaction i hope we are
doing the same thing to them
probably not the right reaction but that
was my is it was pretty bad
and so that's going on we are being
mapped out
so this is another trend unfortunate
trend that is happening
the third one is economic and that is
the fact that and
and and climate wise it's also another
trend yep
people shooting at that substation we
haven't caught these guys
oh they're repercussions it turns out we
were lucky
that that particular substation could be
avoided and route the electricity could
be routed throughout the substation
so the people didn't get the full uh
brunt of of this thing so if we were i
you know it could be a trial run people
were trying out but
it happened
so the other aspect of this is the is
the emergence of renewable electricity
and as as an economic issue
so this is wind electricity the cost of
electricity from the wind
is coming down it's in fact come down
and flattened a little bit
and this is in comparison to others and
this is the by the way
the adoption of wind electricity is
going up exponentially
and it is almost at the same price
or cost in production as wholesale
natural gas electricity cost
and it's cheaper than coal today
the same thing is happening in solar
this is
so while wind is centralized
but it's intermittent solar
is both intermittent and distributed
and i'll come to that it could be at the
edge of the network as opposed to in the
middle of the network
and this is uh in a utility scale solar
this is commercial scale this is
residential scale and this is coming out
at a rate that we
never predicted in fact when steve chu
and i were in the department of energy
we launched something called the sunshot
initiative
to get the cost of solar electricity
down to five cents a kilowatt hour
without subsidies so that it'll be the
cheapest way to produce electricity
and in fact we might reach that before
2020.
and this is comparable the wholesale one
is getting comparable to the natural gas
cost which is the benchmark
and the retail one the rooftop solar is
actually getting comparable as well to
the retail electricity which is where
it's relevant
so this is happening in fact by 2020
we're going to see this to be cheaper
than many other places and i'll that
will i'll come to that in the paradigm
as well
this is already happening in california
to the extent that it
could affect the grid as i said this is
the california load curve
this is about noon and then it flattens
out when people go home
the load goes up and then comes down
again
and what is happening today and it's
going to happen
in the future because of what's
happening at the edges of the network is
the following
this thing this load curve is load is
going to go down and then shoot up
to the point that this is called the
duck curve
because this is the duck's belly and the
duck is getting fatter
and you have a ramp up of about 150 to
200 megawatts a minute
between four o'clock and six o'clock or
so so the question is why is this
happening
the reason this is happening is because
of rooftop solar it's a negative load
and the way it is being you know
deployed we don't know exactly where
those are
so we don't know where the negative load
is coming up and the wholesale market
has this excess electricity so the way
they're trying to handle this is to do
negative pricing
that is they will introduce they'll give
you money
to take the electricity away because
they have excess electricity
so this lack of coordination is a big
deal which is i think where information
could come in and actually
optimize the system so the third
another trend that is happening is
storage this is lithium ion battery cost
coming down
and comparable to getting to lead acid
batteries on a first cost basis
and on a cycle basis even cheaper and
there are other batteries that we funded
from rpe
that are getting competitive as well so
storage is getting cheaper
so if you now put all that together this
is the current paradigm we have
you have a wholesale iso which is let's
say i'm taking a number
selling electricity the electric utility
at about seven cents a kilowatt
hour plus minus fluctuation based on
market
let's say we we assume that and that
elect
utility like pg e is selling you
electricity
at 15 cents a kilowatt hour okay this is
the the market structure this is the
tier structure you hope
that the wholesale price is lower than
the retail price and the
and the utility doesn't go out of
business and that's the paradigm
of the one-way power flow this is what
could happen based on the trends that we
are seeing
you have this same thing going on out
here seven cents plus minus delta
of base to the market's fluctuation and
this may still be 15 cents a kilowatt
hour
but you may be able to in in the near
future
generate electricity from your rooftop
at 10 cents a kilowatt hour
which is cheaper than the retail what
would you do then well
you said i don't want the retail for the
time being when the sun is up there
you may have storage to store that
electricity in various way forms
or if you have a gas line coming to your
home
which most people do you may like to
generate electricity from that and use
the waste heat
to heat up your water this is called
heat combine hidden power
in which case this may actually be even
cheaper than the solar
so now you have this home it's just like
you know if you had
went 30 years ago you had only the
telephone line and the antenna on your
tv
to get your information now you have so
many other ways to get your information
and you can switch
well the same thing could be happening
in the power sector as well
so that now that architecture that i
drew up
in terms of the centralized generation
well you may have some centralized
storage this centralized base load
could not need not be just base load it
could be intermittent as well
and you have storage and you have
generation and storage
at the edges of the network itself now
how do you manage this
and what's the new paradigm that we
should be using
and what i'll tell you is is this is
what's going on this is the first time
in the history that the distributed and
intermittent
is actually getting cheaper than the
centralized base load
and in the history of the electricity
grid
so the past hundred years where
centralized base load generation
follows distributed variable load in the
future we may have centralized base load
plus intermittent generation plus
distributed generation
storage and load which is the in the
producer and consumer prosumer
so who leads who follows and who pays
we don't know that
we had wholesale price always lower than
the retail price so that the utility
makes margin
we don't know what's going to be because
the cost of distributed generation
could be lower than the retail price
isn't this an instability
probably is and a lot of utilities are
worried about this
and finally the consumer has a single
option in the past
and we may have multiple options how
consumer has multiple options for luxury
how does he or she minimize the cost how
does system balance with two-way power
flow
we still have not quite worked it out
so the really is the real issues in
terms of the renewables is that how do
we integrate high penetration
of renewables california has a mandate
now called the renewable portfolio
standard
do we want to get to 33 renewables
by 2020. now if you have that that's a
pretty high penetration
then how do we manage the centralized
intermittent
and the distributed intermittent
resources we still don't have any idea
and what is the problem is in the
dispatch models
in the dispatch we are dispatching 95
percent
of the generation a day ahead well it's
very hard to predict wind power exactly
in our day ahead so what needs to happen
is to transition this to something like
seventy percent out here twenty five
percent
five percent out here so that you have
thirty percent out here
you may expect to get 35 percent wind
for example integrated the question is
how do we do that
and the iso has not quite figured this
out
in terms of control and optimization of
the system
we are going to see more of load
following the generation which is a new
paradigm
the generation always followed the load
but now the gen the load has to follow
the generation which is much cheaper
because you can you know you can then
control if
if your solar light is going down maybe
you can dim the light just a little bit
today we do that only for managing peaks
but it has to be done in a dynamic way
which means the load need to know what
the generation
when the generation is coming down so
information communication has to happen
and someone needs to compute that
so the most cost effective options that
a lot of us see
is that if you want penetration up to 20
to 25
don't put storage because storage is
expensive what you really want to do is
to
the dispatch operation needs to be
changed and
more towards the 15-minute market which
means you have to control
increase or decrease the load to follow
the generation and maybe put new
transmission lines so that you have a
wider area
to balance the grid if you want to go
higher than that
then you want to put storage and other
turbines etc to balance out the
intermittency
a lot of people are asking the question
what about microgrids
what are microgrids because our grid is
just one network
well the micro grid let me explain what
people
mean by that you can take today's grid
which is you know high voltage
generation uh
uh it's a high voltage transmission then
a distribution network
and you have a feeder lines and homes
you could imagine
this to be a microgrid out here
if you could connect with the grid
legacy grid
or disconnect with the legacy grid you
can assume these to be microgrids these
could be independent disconnected could
be connected
as well and you can and this actually
it can take this unit out here and
and maybe this out here and you can form
a microgrid and there's a lot of people
are proposing that as a
as a new way of handling these issues
so how do you connect and disconnect
when necessary
now when you disconnect here there's a
problem
because today you don't have to worry
about frequency your 60 hertz is managed
by your
independent system operator when you
disconnect your appliances still want to
run on 60 hertz
someone has to regulate it someone needs
to regulate your voltage to 120 volts
which is regulated by your grid today so
when you disconnect
you have to get automated and and then
automate load generation balancing
as well as voltage and frequency
regulation disconnect and then
can this unit connect with the grid and
provide the services
to the rest of the grid so as to take
away some eliminate some of the problems
like the duck curve
for the rest of the system so that's a
proposal out there
and it's not you know it's not sure it's
not clear the jury is still out whether
that's the right way to do it
but if you are to do it here is an idea
of
of how that could be operated and this
is just a proposal at the time
because i yeah that we have our own
generation capacity i don't know
stanford i'm here only six months so i
still have to figure this out
because there is power generation that's
right
but i think we may be going we may be
buying power from palo alto i don't know
others may know there's also a gas based
generation yeah
okay okay
in fact we could if this is indeed a
microgrid we could try some experiments
out here
as long as no one brings the grid down
it acts like a municipality then
municipalities actually sacramento for
example is municipality
they're buying electricity and they
manage the pricing
uh it's not the puc and in fact is much
more progressive in that sense
the municipalities i think palo alto is
one
so here is so how do you manage
centralized
distributed which is at the edge of the
network like rooftop solar
or storage and loads and intermittent
which could be both distributed and
centralized in a system operation
and that's that's what we're getting
into in the next decade or so
and we really don't have any idea so
here is a proposal
so you have a legacy grid you have
generation
but now you may have generation at the
edge of the network you have load at the
edge of the network you may have storage
too
if it gets really dirt cheap if the
gigafactory and
and tesla is that successful it'll get
really cheap
so you may have this now how do you
manage this whole operation
so one is to really make some units like
collapse them together into a load
generating units
into a microgrid and then sell that
to the grid in an aggregated way that's
what utilities do they're aggregators
but you can aggregate in many different
ways and microgrid is one of them
well you may want to have and this is a
technology that is
coming on right now is electronic power
conversion
this is going down and going up in
voltage unit using electronics
which is juan rivas and others are doing
it out here
and there are this this is we when we
were in department of energy we felt
that this was very important
we put like 100 million dollars of
funding into new kinds of semiconductors
etc
to do the electronic power conversion
and get it cheaper and cheaper
why is this important because then it's
not only the inversion apart from dc to
ac
but you can control phase angle you can
control you can actually do control of
voltage regulation frequency regulation
using an electronic platform and so this
i think
is very very important and it's not just
power conversion it's switching
in in fact imagine you know
semiconductor-based circuit breakers
and and on monitoring you can measure
the power so imagine you have these at
certain nodes this could be expensive so
imagine this to be only a few depending
on what the cost is
and imagine if these electronic power
conversion
also has a network computing platform
built in so you can send signals for
optimization
now you got a distributed computing
platform you got all these you know
power
you know power conversion and power
management devices else
you know distributed now now the
question is how would you compute how
would you
how would you isolate how would
disconnect remember i told you that when
you disconnect
you got to regulate your frequency and
that has to be in real time
and you need stability of the grid in
real time
at the 16 millisecond time scale because
that's a cycle
so you may have this you may call a
microgrid which you can connect to the
grid and disconnect provide services
you can have another micro grid out here
and you can have an array of microgrids
so you're essentially packaging
now it's very important that if you are
to create microgrids
that there is no when you isolate
yourself
there's no system operator it has to
manage itself
it has to be fully automated and so
local
autonomous estimation and optimal
dispatch
of load generation and storage has to
happen
and that needs algorithms that needs
some you know
that needs distributed algorithms so
that you're not
in a prone to you know threats because
of a single unit
a single point of failure etc so these
have to be developed
okay some of it has been the control
units have been but
full system optimization well i think
that stephen boyd and others are working
on it
but that needs to come together and then
of course
where do you use the cloud people say
cloud computing well
the cloud is is very powerful but you do
have network latencies
and if you rely on the cloud completely
then you have a problem because your
latency
this has to be done in 16 milliseconds
so networking speeds become very
important now
or 16 milliseconds or less because you
want to prevent faults
so you want to use the cloud to collect
the data
to have optimization signals going into
these units
to optimize and minimize the cost but
you don't want to rely completely on
stability
of a grid on the cloud because of
latency issues you have to have
autonomous units
embedded in this you can think of this
as the internet of things if you may
but that's what you really need and that
will create some value
so this is a huge problem that needs to
be resolved and it's not completely
resolved yet these are just proposals
right now
but what is likely to happen is the
following
you have the electricity network which
distributes power
which is geographically distributed you
have a gas
network which is molecules which is
geographically
distributed that's getting coupled and
you have the information network which
is sending out
bits and there's dynamics out here
there's latency there's
you know delays that happen out here
there's this coupling out here as well
and the dynamics of the whole system
it's not digital it's analog
because things are turning up and now
you may have voltage spikes going up and
those all need to be managed that's an
analog
problem and there are big questions out
here
number one is how can we design a
resilient couple networks while
minimizing the cost
i don't think this has been worked out
yet
how can we understand and control system
dynamics
from the sub-cycle to seasonal time
scales in these couple networks
not clear and finally how can we prevent
catastrophic failure
and catastrophic failure let me give you
an example of this
this is what happened in india for two
days
in 2012 where the whole northern part
of the grid just completely collapsed
and 620 million people nine percent of
the world people
lost electricity just came to a
standstill and it turns out it happened
because something called cascading
failure
there was it was hot summer people were
drawing a lot of current and
agricultural pumps
pumps produce reactive power as opposed
to real power
they need reactive power and then the
phase angle between the voltage and
current sort of shifted
and in india they didn't have controls
on those and you draw more current
suddenly one circuit breaker trips
and if one trips all the load or the or
the power is shifted to the rest of the
network
and then another one trips and then you
have a cascading failure
and this happened by the way in 2011 in
san diego the same
issue okay when one failure happened
then it cascaded
the same thing happened in 2003 in new
york area
very similar problem the lessons learnt
were minimal
frankly we don't know how to stop
cascading failure so what we don't know
even in today's network only electricity
network without the information and
natural gas
is that how close are we to a phase
transition like that
okay can we predict it can we stop it
before it happens
can we move away from it and there are
some tell-tale signals like
frequency fluctuation but can we get
insights into that before
so that we can prevent these failures to
happen and that's still a wide-open
area yeah this is my last slide
so this is now we have these sensors
it's time to create some value and the
value is created not just in diagnostic
but in operations and planning etc so
let me stop here
thank you very much
there's a couple of short questions or
clarifications
back up it seems like uh you mentioned
the curve where there's a depression in
the middle of the day
there's the yep the load the floor and
then the uh
spike seems like uh you still need
a great infrastructure that provides for
the peak so therefore
you know if you don't get some kind of
edge storage you still have the same
problems
with just for a brief period of time of
the day that's right
that's absolutely right in fact the
reason i showed this temperature
going to really hot extremes is because
today you got to design the grid for the
extreme
which is very expensive and a storage
would certainly help
but storage is also expensive and i
think the cheapest way to do it
is to control load you follow generation
when you need to
and that means the loads need to know
what the generation is doing the
generation needs to know what the load
is doing
and that means measurement there's data
communication
and some level of computing so that they
are coordinating
and that is not there today one last
question
yeah what what's the impact of getting
rid of daylight savings time
oh boy that is it never quite thought of
that
um because you know right now it
increases the
the air conditioning load a lot yeah i
don't know that
i don't know the answer to that and
frankly i think given this
the duck curve that i talked about is
really due to solar
and if you change it by one hour it
happens to work
yeah actually that's a good question i
don't know
you